hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch international we are continuing
with the match level narnia vs magnus
carlsen and it is the other match of the
semifinals
uh and this is game two in game one
eleven blundered the game uh in a better
position and now
uh we'll see what happens here it also
features a very exciting opening
not as as exciting as the opening from
the previous video uh of course that was
the evans gambit but
a very exciting one so let's check it
out 11 with the white pieces opens with
e4
as he usually does and magnus goes for
knight to
knight to f6 so alejandro's defense is
on the board
uh we have e5 eleven advances the pawn
challenges the knight
knight to d5 and c4 we have knight to b6
and
of course d4 we have d6 and here you
could choose a lot of different ideas
you could choose to go f4 you could
choose to go knight to f3
also popular or you can just capture on
d6 which is what 11 does
so c captures and now knight to c3
continuing development and the g6 magnus
wants the fiance the bishop and castle
king side
uh we have bishop to e3 and bishop to g7
now and here
while you could continue just developing
with a bishop to e2 or knight to f3
uh white doesn't want to allow bishop to
g4 after knight to f3 so first 11 goes
h3 he prepares it magnus castles and now
knight to f3 and here knight to c6 uh
just continuing development 11 grabs
more space in the center with the d5 and
knight to a5 now with a double attack on
the c4 pawn
however uh 11 ignores it with bishop to
d4 and this doesn't really blunder upon
because if you if you would go for the
pawn let's say knight captures
then you have bishop captures captures
and now just captures and after captures
of course queen to d4 check
and if black doesn't want to lose a
piece here you have to block and then
white just reclaims the pawn after queen
captures on e5
so you don't really win a pawn so here
you could try something like h6 you
could try e5 also a popular idea
for example e5 captures captures and the
game just normally continues to wear
black mounts more pressure on the c4
pawn
however magnus goes for bishop captures
on d4
with queen captures on d4 it's an
excellent square for the queen now uh so
now you have to
either get rid of the queen by playing
e5 or or try something else and e5 is an
excellent move
uh because it does get rid of the queen
so you either move the queen or you
capture alpha song
and then you free the c6 square for the
black knight so d
captures on e6 we have bishop captures
on e6 and now
uh there is a game in the database where
b3 was played
just strengthening that c for pawn but
here uh 11 goes for a new idea
knights to e4 and it is uh already as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game and now
he's threatening knight to f6 check
which would expose
the king to this diagonal which is what
11 11 is going for
however now that the c6 square has been
vacated for black's knight uh of course
knight to c6 and now the problem is uh
you cannot uh
keep this pressure you cannot keep the
queen on this diagonal for example if
queen to c3
or something like that knight the a4 uh
is very strong
just going after the queen so first uh
instead of just moving the queen 11
first goes knight to f6
check king to h8 and now the problem is
the same
if your queen wasn't under attack you'd
have a lot of nasty discoveries
uh and queen to c3 is still off limits
knights to a4 is just too strong for
example your queen is under attack you
have to move it
and the d squares are taken so wherever
you move it let's say queen c2 now comes
queen captures on f6
you do win back your piece but now queen
captures on b2 and the white is lost you
have to save the rook
let's say rook d1 but now queen c3 check
and after the knight blocks queen e5
check bishop e2 and now you just go
after the bishop and there is no uh
defense against this
uh you would have to castle uh give up
the the bishop and
just have a completely lost game so
instead after this uh
attack on the queen of queen to f4 while
keeping an eye on the knight here
and now bishop to f5 uh now preparing to
capture the knight so eleven goes back
uh knight to g4 and now rook to e8
check so magnus was able to offend off
the attack and now he's on
uh on the counter attack so uh the queen
the king is in check we have bishop to
e2 blocking
knights to e3 might have been a bit more
precise as
after bishop to e2 magnus goes for
bishop to d3 now
puts pressure on the bishop now now
ignites the e3 but now bishop captures
an e2
prevents the king from castling so king
captures and
you might able to be be able to
artificially castle
after rook to e1 and king to f1 however
d5 magnus immediately
goes for it as white king is still in
the center of the board
so now if you if you capture them
captures there's a lot of pressure going
on here
not very not very pleasant for white so
instead
knight the g5 eleven decides i'm not
going on the defensive i'm going on the
offensive so knight captures on f7 is
the threat
of picking up the queen so queen the e7
by magnus now offering the f7 pawn
although capturing it isn't all that
great because after capturing king g7
with a double attack on the knight
you lose a piece because if you go back
d4 wins this knight you cannot move it
so after this queen to a7 idea we have
rook
h the e1 you could go back with king to
f1 to avoid
d4 now however 11 says i'm going to
sacrifice a piece and
continue with my attack so rook h to e1
and magnus goes for it we have d4 now
the knight uh
i cannot move so king to f1 now as 11
did not want to box in his rook
so d captures on e3 with rook captures
on e3
and only now after the queen moves queen
d7 we have knight captures on f7 with
check so the attack is happening uh but
we'll see
if it will be if it will be uh strong
enough of an attack
so king g7 and now rook f3 preparing
queen to f6
check uh however queen to d for by
magnus now defending the f6 square but
also
uh he's up a piece so he just wants to
trade queens and
before uh trading queens 11 goes for
knight to d6 and it's a very good move
um because if for example magnus
decides to trade queen trade queens then
knight captures an 8 with
check a nice in-between move rook
captures and narrow captures on f4
yes black still has two knights for a
rook however white is up two pawns and
you should have uh
sufficient compensation so after knight
to d6
magnus goes rook to e7 instead also
keeps an eye
on the on the f7 square and now comes
queen captures on d4 there's not much
not much else to do here there's no way
to increase the pressure
or prolong the attack so queen captures
on d4 we have knight captures and now
rook to d3 going after the knight but
now knight back to c6
uh and here b3 defending this knight
defending the pawn
so here uh 11 is up two pawns however
magnus is
up a full knight so uh we'll see what
happens with knight to d7 preparing to
remane over the knight to the center of
the board rook a to d1 doubling up on
the d file and now
knight to c5 attacking the rook we have
rook 3 to d2
uh and now a5 not preventing any b4
ideas
to this large uh carlson's knight we
have g3
and now uh even a4 and now uh the the b
for pawn uh can the b pawn cannot move
to b4 since the knight
still guards the b4 square so rook to b2
uh but now knight to b4 knight to b4
with
the with the idea that if white plays
something let's say h4 you want to
capture on b3 and
attack the b3 pawn that's that's what's
what carlson is going for
so 11 decides to capture on a4 uh and
now of course aurora captures on a4 puts
pressure on the pawn here
a3 tries to get rook captures and rook
captures here
but now of course magnus just goes
knight b to d3
attacks the rook here and now rook to b3
11 played this rook to b3 move in front
of the knight
but it's not much better once you move
the knight
the rook let's say rugby beat the d2 uh
black can just capture here and now
black
grabbed another pawn and it's just a
completely winning endgame for black
so instead uh let me just play it rook
to b3 and here
magnus grabbed the rook and uh well it
was in this position on move 37 that 11
resigned the game
and uh game two also goes to magnus
carlsen and
i don't know if we will be showing any
more games from the match i do suggest
them if they were
like really awesome i still haven't had
the chance to check all of them
uh but magnus was was better uh
on the first day of the semi-finals as
out of the sixth game as uh
they played magnus one three and three
of the games were drawn
so still no wins for 11 in this match
but it is is still very early in the
match so we'll see what happens
so yeah that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh brian carrion
gregory
rumister uh organelle
aurobor carson zima and serge kramer for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of uh the clutch
chest international
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world and
we will check up on pog chat champs at
some point uh but
there's too much going on at the moment
i simply can't cover everything
uh and yeah uh the friday arenas are
continuing the links are in the
description below so do join both meadow
arena and
the friday arena uh are being played
today i will stream your games so
uh do do join it's gonna be it's gonna
be awesome
and also i will put a link to our
leeches team so you can join the team so
uh you always know when there's an event
going on so you can join
without actually watching a video where
i talk about it
so yeah uh once again i do hope you
enjoyed it and
have an excellent rest of your day